in the world of electric vehicles
there's one name
tesla i'm 19 year today tesla's recent
stock surge
tesla notching up another record today
tesla of course and then there's
everyone else
and one of tesla's biggest customers
right now
china the country is quickly becoming
the fastest growing purchaser of
electric vehicles
or evs in the world it's like a
nine-fold increase over the last 10
decade and china already surpassed like
japan and europe and has been the kind
of the world's largest ep market
so far china is a huge game changer and
some say that
by 2030 about 40 percent of tesla sales
will come from china
but tesla isn't the only eevee company
on the block
far from it as a result of that
skyrocketing demand
there are now over 600 ev companies in
china
vying to compete with the electric car
giant
there are several startup companies who
kind of see the moment and neil is one
of them
neo one of china's brightest ev
companies is on the tips of both
consumers
as well as investors tongues over the
course of 2020
neo's stock price increased a thousand
percent
and investors threw around terms like
the chinese tesla
and the tesla killer it has many names
but essentially it is one of the most
promising and the most prominent
electric vehicle companies that have
come out of china in recent years
but just two years ago the company was
nearly bankrupt
this is the story of how neo came back
from the brink of bankruptcy
to become one of the hottest electric
vehicle companies on the planet
to put neo's importance into perspective
it's valued higher than american car
manufacturing giant
gm this company which was worth about
four billion dollars by the end of 2019
is now a 94 billion dollar behemoth
according to its valuation
in the u.s markets in 2020 the company
saw
record demand for its model lineup with
year-over-year growth of 121 percent
and with the release of the et7 sedan in
early 2021
the stock immediately took another jump
very similar to tesla in some instances
that the company
has been focusing on really promoting as
of itself as this
digital or premium electric car
manufacturer
but also like trying to to make it more
appealing to the
the middle class consumers in china
we are always very clear about our
target user groups
for example the price of our et7 is
similar to the ones of the best-selling
mid-size
or full-size sedans in china like bmw's
five-class
audi a6 mercedes-benz e-class
neo isn't a recent startup that came out
of nowhere
chinese ev startups started to pop up
around 2014
the year neo was founded because of
subsidies offered by the chinese
government
european government china itself they
have all come out and said that they
want to
move into cleaner uh transportation
solutions which essentially at this
point means electric vehicles
china started to promote electric
vehicles back in like
almost a decade ago so at that time it
was only a thousand
uh electric vehicles and still sold in
annually
fast forward to 2018 and annual sales
were easily eclipsing one
million cars in china and william lee
the founder of neo who's also
no stranger to the auto market saw that
spike and decided to make the jump into
the ev market
who himself is somewhat of a serial
entrepreneur
somewhat light like elon musk the
company founded before this was bit auto
and it's a online based service platform
for
for vehicles in general he's kind of a
person with really deep knowledge
in both the it business but also the
automotive industries
but nia wasn't always on a clear path to
success
there's a reason ev stocks are so
volatile
and it's because at any moment companies
are teetering on the edge of bankruptcy
and neo was no exception it was a
smallish
fairly new car company
that faced these really major
fire related recalls early in the year
and then its sales were withering and
for that there are many reasons
its most formidable arrival which is
tesla entered the chinese market in
2019.
alongside competition from tesla sales
of electric cars plateaued in 2019
partly because of decisions taken by the
chinese government
the chinese government cupped the direct
purchase subsidies for electric vehicles
by over 50 percent
in 2019 which is like the largest ever
cut compared to previous years so for
some particular automakers
the the subsidy card really have a huge
negative impact on them
the company started bleeding money it
lost about 1.6 billion dollars in 2019
the valuation kind of shows the picture
here the
the stock really tanked it's been a very
rough
few months for this company they've had
to deal with layoffs they're trying to
reduce this workforce by
about 14 the troubles became so intense
that uh the company came out and said
that it might not have liquidity for
even 12 months but in early 2020
neo's fortunes changed while china's
subsidy cuts almost sank the company
an investment from a chinese province
saved it
neo managed to strike a deal with this
uh
chinese city of cafe in february 2020
they basically did this help neo
injected the cash flows and help them
to deal with the cash flow issues as
part of the deal
neo agreed to establish headquarters in
the city of jefe's economic and
technological development area
as well as provide investors a 24.1
percent stake in the company
it also got um you know credit
facilities from local banks
to the tune of almost one and a half
billion dollars and that kind of really
let the
liquidity concerns take a backstage both
for investors and also the company
to take it mind off the money game and
kind of really focus
on making those cars and delivering
those cars
investors were confident that with
liquidity problems taking a back seat
neil could finally tackle the monumental
task of scaling up the manufacturing of
its vehicles
unlike tech firms that can reach
billions of customers through the
internet
large car makers need to manufacture
products at enormous scale and rely on
huge supply chains now the traditional
auto companies
got this really packed down
but it has also got more than 100 years
of experience behind it
so scaling up was a big problem for
tesla because as
musk famously said tesla was not trying
to invent the machine which means the
car
but actually the machine that makes the
machine which means
tesla or musk was were trying to
re-imagine
the auto manufacturing process and
manufacturing is what neo is hoping will
give them an edge
while their es6 suv costs more than a
third more than that of tesla's model 3
sedan
neo is using innovative features and
services to bring their costs down
the biggest thing that neo is doing
differently from tesla is that it has
outsourced its manufacturing to a
state-owned company which has more
experience in this matter
instead of building a factory of its own
like tesla does with its gigafactories
neo uses a contract manufacturer the
state-owned jac
motors another big difference is neo's
subscription model
that aims to simplify ownership by
taking away the risks of owning the
battery part of the vehicle
and so what the customers would do is
just buy this car or the car shell so to
speak
and and rent the battery from neo
for a monthly fee so if you choose a
subscription model it actually reduced
the price by around like
uh 10 000 rmv which is like 20
or 15 of the upfront price for for a new
car
the final difference between tesla and
neo is how they both approach the
problem of
range anxiety which is the term for how
ev owners worry that their battery will
run out before they reach their
destination
when your battery runs out you have to
park into a charging station and wait
for sometimes for hours until your you
know battery is
charged up enough for you to hit the
road back right
so what neo is uh suggesting people do
is make use of their battery swap
services so in this
a new car user would essentially drive
into this
uh swapping station and in a matter of
few minutes
neo says about three minutes their
depleted battery could be taken
out and replaced with a fully charged
battery and they just go back on
and go back and hit the road while tesla
tried their own battery swap service in
2015
it was discontinued due to lack of
interest neo was banking on the fact
that a battery swap service back in 2015
was ahead of its time
the market was just not mature enough
people were just not as
comfortable with evs at that point neo
says they're working on a second
generation of swapping stations
and plans to add 300 more of those
stations around china
in 2021 the chinese ev market is set to
surge to 1.8 million vehicles in 2021
and neo plans to build a hundred and
fifty thousand
cars quadrupling its output of 43
000 vehicles from 2020. however neo's
competition is about to get much
stiffer they won't just be facing
competition from tesla
and other chinese ev manufacturers
global automakers are also doubling down
on china's ev market recognizing the
gross potential of it
volkswagen and toyota they all
start to increase the investments in
ev technologies along with their chinese
joint venture partners
and whether neo can not only fend off
competition in china
but carve out a path for itself around
the world to become a household name
remains to be seen